♪
>>> SO JOE BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND AS HE SAYS, THAT MEANS THE
BUCK STOPS WITH HIM ON THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE AFGHANISTAN
PULLOUT.
BUT THERE IS A GROWING LIST OF
PEOPLE BLAMING PRESIDENT TRUMP,
INCLUDING FORMER TRUMP PEOPLE.
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>>> MOST AMERICANS SEEM TO LIKE
THE IDEA OF WITHDRAWING FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT THEY DON'T LIKE THE WAY JOE
BIDEN HAS DONE IT.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO NEW CBS
POLL.
NOW THAT DELTA IS A POLITICAL
PROBLEM FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
GIVEN HIS ADMINISTRATION IS
PREDICATED UPON THE PROMISE OF
COMPETENCE AND COMPASSION, BUT
IT'S THAT HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
THAT SHOULD REALLY BE DRIVING
AMERICAN OPINIONS.
AS LO GIST CAT MATTER, THIS HAS
BEEN A DISASTER.
SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT THE
BENEFITS OF SMALL RESIDUAL FORCE
RATHER THAN COMPLETE ABANDONMENT
OF BAGRAM AIR FORCE WOULD BE
BETTER.
THIS SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT HOW WE
GOT HERE.
>> OUR SECRETARY OF STATE SIGNED
A SURRENDER AGREEMENT TO THE
TALIBAN.
THIS COLLAPSE GOES BACK TO THE
CAPITULATION AGREEMENT OF 2020.
I MEAN, THE TALIBAN DIDN'T
DEFEAT US.
WE DEFEATED OURSELVES.
>> A SURRENDER AGREEMENT THAT'S
RETIRED LIEUTENANT GENERAL H.R.
McMASTER FORMING MIKE POMPEO FOR
HIS NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
TALIBAN.
THAT INEXPUBLICLY EXCLUDED OUR
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT.
MARK ESPER ALSO WEIGHED IN ON
CNN WHILE RIGHTFULLY BLAMING THE
BIDEN ADMISSION STRAGS FOR THE
BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL, HE DID NOT
SPARE THE EXPRESIDENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP BY CONTINUING
TO WANT TO WITHDRAW AMERICAN
FORCES OUT OF AFGHANISTAN
UNDERMINED THE AGREEMENT.
I OBJECTED THAT WE NOT REDUCE
BELOW 4,500 TROOPS UNLESS AND
UNTIL CONDITIONS WERE MET BY THE
TALIBAN.
OTHERWISE WE WOULD SEE A NUMBER
OF THINGS PLAY OUT, WHICH ARE
UNFOLDING RIGHT NOW.
>> WHICH IS A REMINDER THAT NOT
ONLY WAS THE DEAL DONE WITH THE
TALIBAN NO GOOD BUT THAT TRUMP
WAS CALLING FOR A COMPLETE PULL
OUT OF U.S. TROOPS BY LAST
CHRISTMAS.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE
ABRUPT.
NOW ONE OF THE AREAS RIGHTFULLY
INSPIRING THE MOST GRIEF IS THE
FAILURE TO HAVE A STREAMLINED
PROCESS TO SAVE THE AFGHANS WHO
AIDED OUR MILITARY EFFORTS.
ON THIS FRONT, FORMER PENCE AIDE
OLIVIA TROY ACCUSED TRUMP A
E
ADVISER STEPHEN MILLER.
THERE WERE CABINET MEETINGS
ABOUT THIS DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION STEPHEN MILLER
PEDAL HIS RACIST ABOUT IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
HE AND HIS ENABLERS WOULD
UNDERMINE ANYONE WHO WORKED ON
SOLVING THE SIV ISSUE BY
DEVASTATING THE SYSTEM AT DHS
AND STATE.
STEPHEN MILLER BLAMED BIDEN
DESPITE HIS OWN CLEAR RECORD OF
ADVOCATING RESTRICTIONS ON
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
NOT HELPED BY THE FACT THAT
ARTICLES HAD LONG BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT HOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS DRAMATICALLY
DROPPED VISAS FOR AFGHAN AND
IRAQI INTERPRETERS.
SO THIS RINGS HALLOW.
LIKE WHEN NIKKI HALEY TWEETED TO
HAVE OUR GENERAL SAY THEY'RE
DEPENDING ON DIPLOMACY WITH THE
TALIBAN IS UNBELIEVABLE SCENARIO
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TALIBAN IS
LIKE DEALING WITH THE DEVIL.
I AGREE.
BUT HER COMMENTS WOULD HAVE A
LOT MORE CREDIBILITY IF SHE
HADN'T VOCALLY BACKED TALIBAN
NEGOTIATIONS WHEN THEY WERE
BEING PUSHED BY HER FORMER BOSS
SAYING, THE U.S. POLICY IN
AFGHANISTAN IS WORKING.
WE'RE SEEING THAT WE'RE CLOSER
TO TALKS WITH THE TALIBAN IN THE
PEACE PROCESS THAN WE HAVE SEEN
BEFORE.
LOOK, FROM WHATEVER WAY YOU LOOK
AT IT, U.S. POLICY IN
AFGHANISTAN IS NOT WORKING AND
WHILE THE COLLAPSE FINALLY
OCCURRED ON JOE BIDEN'S WATCH,
THE POLICY OF ABANDONING
AFGHANISTAN TO THE TALIBAN BEGAN
UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT'S YOUR REALITY CHECK.
>> INDEED IT IS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JOHN AVLON.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN OLIVIA
TROY, A FORMER ADVISER TO VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND HAS
PUSHED BACK AGAINST THIS IDEA
THAT THE WITHDRAWAL AND
EVACUATION OPERATIONS WOULD HAVE
GONE SMOOTHLY UNDER FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
AND IN PARTICULAR, OLIVIA, YOU
HAVE AS WE HEARD IN THAT REALITY
CHECK THERE SORT OF PULLED BACK
THE CURTAIN ON WHAT WENT ON
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AS FAR AS GETTING THESE FOLKS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF,
PEOPLE WHO HELPED U.S. TROOPS
GETTING THEM THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOU'RE IN MEETINGS ABOUT THIS
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
PERSONAL TO YOU.
YOU DID SERVE AS A CIVILIAN ON
AND OFF IN AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT WOULD SAY STEPHEN MILLER
SAY IN THESE MEETINGS AS HE
ARGUED AGAINST RELIEF FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS?
>> WELL, IT WAS REALLY HARD TO
HEAR HIS STATEMENTS AND THEY
WERE SAID VERY OPENLY IN FRONT
OF CABINET LEVEL PEOPLE AND VERY
SENIOR STAFF PEOPLE AND WOULD
SAY, WELL WHAT DO YOU WANT?
DO YOU WANT A BUNCH OF LITTLE
IRAQS IN STANDS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
IT WAS HURTFUL TO HEAR THAT AND
OFFENSIVE.
TO MANY OF US IN THE ROOM WHO
HAD SERVED ON THE GROUND IN BOTH
COUNTRIES.
I'VE BEEN TO BOTH COUNTRIES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HELPED
KEEP US ALIVE.
HELPED NAVIGATE US AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
AND TO HEAR THIS, YOU KNOW,
NAIVE HATEFUL RHETORIC BEING
SAID IN CABINET-LEVEL
DISCUSSIONS WHEN WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS SPECIFICALLY ON ITEMS
LIKE THE REFUGEE CEILING AND
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO HEAR
THAT RHETORIC WE KNEW WHAT WE
WERE UP AGAINST.
>> SO WHAT HAPPENED WHEN TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS LIKE
YOURSELF WERE TRYING TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON THESE IMMIGRANT
VISAS AND RELIEF FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAD HELPED THE U.S.?
>> WELL, YOU WOULD FIND THIS IS
A VERY CUMBERSOME, CHALLENGING
SYSTEM ALREADY.
IT IS VERY HARD FOR MANY OF
THESE APPLICANTS TO ACTUALLY GET
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND ACTUALLY
GET THEIR VISA ISSUED.
AND BE ABLE TO BE ELIGIBLE TO
LEAVE.
WHAT YOU FIND IS THE RESOURCES
THERE, THIS ENTIRE THING WAS
BEING GUTTED AND UNDERRESOURCED.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
ON A YEARLY BASIS, YOU'LL SEE
THAT A LOWER AND LOWER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE GET APPROVED AND THE
VISAS DON'T GET ISSUED.
I REMEMBER SPECIFICALLY THERE
WAS ONE TIME WHERE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE WAS UPSET AT A
STORY, A NEWS STORY, THAT HE HAD
SEEN ON THE FRONT PAGE OF A
NEWSPAPER.
SO I GOT THE PIECE OF PAPER ON
MY DESK THAT SAID, WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THIS?
WHY ARE -- WHY HAVE THEY BEEN
STUCK IN THIS PROCESS FOR TWO
YEARS?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DAYS OF
THESE PEOPLE BEING STUCK IN THE
PROCESS, THEY WERE STUCK FOR
THREE YEARS AND THAT NUMBER
INCREASES UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINI
ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN I CALLED TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, I FOUND THAT THERE
WAS ONE PERSON, ONE PERSON,
DOING THE SECURITY CHECKS THERE
FOR THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND THIS
IS I THINK IN 2009.
AND THIS IS A YEAR AFTER THERE
HAD BEEN A CRITICAL DECISION
SAYING WE WILL PRIORITIZE THIS
IRREGARDLESS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> IN 2019 YOUR MEAN?
>> 2019, SORRY.
>> NO WORRIES.
I WANTED TO DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT.
LOOK, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT I MEAN THE
HEINOUS THINGS REALLY THAT YOU
HEARD STEPHEN MILLER SAY IN
THESE MEETINGS, THEY'RE NOT THAT
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT SOME FOLKS,
ESPECIALLY IN RIGHT WING MEDIA,
ARE SAYING NOW ABOUT WHY THESE
PEOPLE WHO HELPED THE U.S.
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO COME
IN.
THEY'RE PAINTING THEM AS
INVADERS.
>> YES.
>> DO YOU SEE A DIRECT LINK
THERE?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THESE ARE CLASSIC TALKING POINTS
THAT WERE ESPOUSED THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE TENURE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS ANTI-IMMIGRANT,
ANTI-REFUGEE RHETORIC.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
IT'S TERRIBLE TO HEAR THESE
THINGS SAID ONCE AGAIN WHEN
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE, THERE SIDE BY
SIDE WITH OUR MILITARY, OUR
CIVILIANS AND OFFICERS ON THE
GROUND LIKE MYSELF AND MEDIA AND
NGOs, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU TRAVEL TO THESE COUNTRIES
AND YOU NEED THESE PEOPLE AND
YOU NEED THEM TO BE YOUR ALLIES.
TO SEND THIS MESSAGE TO THE
WORLD SAYING WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HELP THESE PEOPLE STARTING WITH
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THE WAY
THEY BEHAVED IS DEPLORABLE.
THIS IS WHY I FOUND IT SO
UPSETTING.
I SAID, YEAH, WE'RE IN A
CRITICAL AND VERY TOUGH
SITUATION ON THE GROUND THERE
RIGHT NOW.
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET THE CONTEXT
OF WHERE A LOT OF THIS STARTED
WHERE THE CRISIS WAS BUILT AND
HOW WE DROPPED THE BALL ON THIS.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROCESSED THE ENTIRE TIME IN THE
TENURE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, ESPECIALLY SINCE
HE WAS THE ONE NEGOTIATING WITH
THE TALIBAN WHICH IS LUDICROUS
AND PLANNING FOR THIS
WITHDRAWAL.
I HAVE NO CONFIDENCE.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN ANY
OF THESE PEOPLE OUT.
SO NOW WE'RE IN THE SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO GET OUT OF THE
COUNTRY AND IT'S TOUGH.
>> OLIVIA, LOOK, I KNOW THIS IS
PERSONAL FOR YOU.
I KNOW THAT WHEN THESE
PROVINCIAL CAPITALS WERE FALLING
YOU WEREN'T JUST THINKING, THIS
IS KANDAHAR.
YOU ARE THINKING THE PEOPLE, THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE WHO HELPED KEEP
YOU SAFE WHEN YO